feels a little odd to sing Halle Halle
hallelujah after weeping and gnashing of
teeth let us pray holy God break open
your word so that we can see the gospel
the good news in the midst of these
tough texts may the words of my mouth
and the meditations of each one of our
hearts be pleasing in your sight Oh God
you are our rock and our Redeemer amen
this is how I wake up in the morning
lovely harp it beckons me from the side
of my bed where I can gently wake up and
face a new day but if I had to give a
sound effect for these texts today this
is what it sounds like if you've come
here today seeking solace and comfort if
you hope this sermon is going to sound
like that beautiful harp music you need
to wait about nine minutes and 30
seconds till I get to that because i
just cannot ignore the intense wake up
call of the gospel this morning it is a
crazy loud alarm that demands our
attention let's start with Paul and his
words to the Thessalonians the day of
the Lord will come like a thief in the
night he implores them to keep awake and
be sober remember all of the
speculations about the end of the world
back in May what hype and yet most of us
paid attention to the hype didn't we
maybe if just to joke a little bit about
those poor college seniors who might not
get to actually graduate should the
world end a few days before commencement
but this was no joking matter for some
not hype but instead deep conviction
followed by devastation when it didn't
happen as predicted Markley would
suggest however
that the question shouldn't be when is
the world going to end the question
instead is how shall we live in the
meantime last Sunday after worship I met
a woman who is visiting in our
congregation she'd returned to Yale with
her husband for his 50th class reunion
from Yale Law School she said it was
great being back at Yale but she was
surprised at what she discovered about
this class of theirs how many classmates
had died since their last reunion most
of them well into their 70s their group
was shrinking showing its age but even
more surprising to this woman was the
group of alums back for their 60th class
reunion such a tiny group she said and
they looked so much older so much more
weary than our class in just 10 short
years and then she looked at me with
pretty wide eyes time is running out I
just realized that our days are numbered
her wake-up call of mortality convinced
her all the more that she was supposed
to risk comfort convenient and in her
case even arrest she explained that if
she hadn't been with us that Sunday
morning she really would have wished to
be with her son and circling in the
circle of protesters in Washington DC
protesting the Keystone XL pipeline she
shared that her son had grown very
passionate in his opposition of this
proposed pipeline and the threat of its
effects on the environment he was going
to washington d.c a second time last
weekend to protest and she wished she
could be there with him she was prepared
to be arrested she said it my place in
life what do I have to lose I have no
reason not to do this it's not as if
this woman had been asleep her whole
life but last weekend she realized in a
new way that her days are indeed
numbered it was time to live out her
convictions now the Apostle Paul pleads
so then let us not fall asleep as others
do but let us keep awake Paul's wake-up
call is not a call to fear he assures
his community that they are already
children of light that God has destined
them for salvation through Christ but
Paul warns with the language of that
blaring alarm keep awake trust in
Christ's coming but don't just sit there
there is work to be done Martin Luther
is said to have promised even if I knew
that tomorrow was the end of the world I
would plant an apple tree today and this
inspiring visitor in our midst last
weekend is living sentiment all or she
is living that sentiment all the more
urgently now a second wake-up call comes
of course in Matthew's Gospel today we
hear this parable about three slaves
each is given a large large sum of money
the first to invest their money get a
huge return on this investment and
please their master very much the third
slave is terrified of this kind of
reckless investing he doesn't want to
risk everything and he buries his money
in the ground obviously it doesn't
multiply there in the dirt and his
master is furious there are many many
interpretations of this parable most
commentary side with one of these
characters but rarely the same one
interestingly enough some believe the
master is the one to favor in this story
he risked large sums of money by giving
it away to the slaves he gave them the
opportunity to risk he was clearly the
wise one others believe that this
parable is about the two slaves who
doubled their money sure such a large
return on their investment involved
immense risk but to please the master
the risk is worth it finally we could
side with the third slave the one
condemned to outer darkness where there
will be weeping and gnashing of teeth
but he was appropriately cautious don't
you think he didn't want to lose even a
fraction of that large sum of money
gifted to him and he had the guts to
stand up to the master at the end told
him just how harsh she was to his slaves
we can sympathize with him to this
parable is about risk no matter who you
side with and our version too faithful
risk God's call to faithful risk and
Christ's example a faithful risk I will
continue to say faithful risk because as
one of your chaplains I cannot encourage
all risk risky behavior particularly
among students is unfortunately what
keeps your chaplains awake at night but
maybe the opposite of faithful risk is
fear driven by perfectionism fear that
paralyzes us at the very moment when God
is throwing open doors and asking us to
walk through them fear that makes us
question our worth as children of God
fear that can sound louder than the yes
of the gospel this kind of spiritual
fear so has your chaplains concerned and
while I may be as risk-averse as many of
you I really believe each of us is
called to faithful risk in this kind of
risk we are fully alive in Christ what
is faithful risk I think it is the
father who never gave up hope of a
reunion with his sons despite decades of
being cut off from them following a
bitter divorce it is his eldest son who
finally worked up the nerve to find him
and call him and ask to meet his father
it is the yes over the phone and finally
getting to meet the grandchildren he
didn't even know he had faithful risk is
Jesus weeping for his dear friend
turning his face toward Jerusalem eating
with the wrong people for giving
everyone faithful risk is saying I'm
sorry or I love you or I need
help not knowing just what the other
person might say in return faithful risk
for some is even walking through these
chapel doors some of us are naturally
quite cautious some of us are naturally
risk takers so you and God need to sort
out what kind of risk will be faithful
for you faithful risk rarely makes
headlines nor is it convenient it is not
risk for our benefit but serves other
people and God it is risky because we
will lose a bit of pride or control in
the process but the gospel wake-up call
is a challenge to ask what we've been
given by God look at where we may have
buried it out of fear and ask ourselves
how we might use these buried treasures
in faithful ways my favorite
interpretation of this gospel parable is
spun in a new way by anna carter
florence she reimagines this story in
which jesus is going on a journey and he
gives three disciples the gospel to one
he gives stories to another he gives
compassion and to the third he gives the
bread of life and cup of salvation the
first disciple ventures out and shares
those stories of Jesus life with others
and they to become disciples the second
gave compassion to others who in turn
would be bearers of compassion as they
are disciples now and the third disciple
digs a hole in the ground and berries
that bread of life and cup of salvation
this sounds a little bit different than
Matthews version in which the first two
slaves sound like smarmy investment
bankers but this isn't about them it's
about that third guy who out of fear
buries his treasure and not his own
treasure God's treasure temporarily
entrusted to him
bread and cup for his neighbors starving
for these gifts of God someone somewhere
along the line may have shared these
same gospel treasures with you and now
that these treasures are in our hands
what will we do with them bury them out
of fear dump them on the ground or risk
losing our pride comfort or control by
speaking up when injustice is happening
or going out of our way to offer
compassion or coming out as Christians
even if we're not sure what others might
think or noticing who is hungry and
sharing bread well these may sound risky
to you John Buchanan puts it in this
framework the greatest risk of all it
turns out is not to risk anything not to
care deeply and profoundly enough about
anything to invest deeply to give your
heart away and in the process risk
everything that is the biggest risk to
not risk anything now it's been nine
minutes and 30 seconds so it's time for
some reassurance because I know that
many of you are ridiculously tired right
now and now you feel like you have to
put faithful risk on your to-do list and
then feel really guilty when you don't
have time or energy and you're just not
able to do it if everything I've said so
far feels impossible just forget it
forget the thief in the night forget the
weeping and gnashing of teeth forget
having to make the right decisions by
yourself forget where you buried that
treasure if you remember anything
remember Paul's words to the
Thessalonians not mine they are
consolation for those of us who love
risk and those of us who check the locks
on the doors of our hearts several times
a day there are good news for today
whether we are awake or asleep we may
live with
Jesus Christ therefore encourage one
another and build up each other as
indeed you are doing amen